[Música]
gracias y buenas tardes a todos
probablemente y con suerte todos penséis
que venimos del mono
pues me gustaría intentar cambiarnos la
vida
y es que si miramos un poquito más atrás
en la historia está claro que los
humanos y todos los seres de cuatro
patas que caminamos sobre la tierra
venimos de un anfibio
los anfibios fueron los primeros
animales que se aventuraron a dejar los
mares hace unos 370 millones de años
en estos ambientes terrestres primitivos
los anfibios fueron la especie dominante
eran depredadores gigantescos y pueden
intimidar hasta un dinosaurio
pero qué es exactamente un anfibio
los anfibios son un grupo de animales
extraordinarios
actualmente hay casi 8000 especies de
anfibios descritas con una variedad de
colores formas y estrategias para la
supervivencia espectaculares
pero todos tienen una cosa en común y es
que los anfibios son capaces de vivir
tanto en ambientes acuáticos como
terrestres
de hecho anfibios significa precisamente
eso que vive en los dos ambientes
esto ha hecho que sean un grupo animal
muy versátil y exitoso y que se
encuentren en todos los continentes
excepto en la antártida
los anfibios son vertebrados eso quiere
decir que tiene una columna vertebral
como nosotros que les aguanta pero a
diferencia de nosotros son animales de
sangre fría eso quiere decir que su
temperatura corporal depende de la
temperatura ambiente pero esto llega a
tal punto que en climas fríos algunas
especies son capaces de congelarse
completamente durante el invierno y
renacer en primavera
y es que los anfibios tienen algunas
características únicas en el reino
animal la mayoría pasan por una
metamorfosis que significa una
transformación completa de su cuerpo y
el paso de larvas acuáticas a adultos
terrestres
como veis o espero que veáis esta
metamorfosis supone unos cambios
anatómicos dramáticos como el
crecimiento de patas la pérdida de las
branquias la reabsorción de la cola es
que incluso la formación de pulmones
desde cero
de hecho la respiración es quizás una de
las cosas más sorprendentes de los
anfibios y es que pueden utilizar hasta
cuatro tipos de respiración distinta
cuando son larvas todas las especies
pueden respirar gracias a un precioso
árbol de branquias pero es que después
de llevar semanas meses o incluso años
debajo del agua de pronto pueden salir a
la superficie y sus pulmones empiezan a
funcionar como si la vida les diera una
segunda oportunidad
además todas las especies respiran a
través de la piel os imagináis poder
estar flotando boca abajo en la piscina
durante horas con el solecito en la
espalda mientras la piel de nuestra
barriga va respirando por nosotros sería
fantástico verdad pues ellos son capaces
de esto
por eso su piel es tan delicada y llena
de vasos porque además de participar en
la respiración también es un órgano
vital para ellos la piel ya que ayuda al
balance de agua y de sales minerales en
su cuerpo
tristemente los anfibios hoy son el
grupo animal más amenazado de la tierra
con más de un 40% de sus especies en
peligro de extinción y desapareciendo
más rápido que las aves los mamíferos o
incluso los corales que hoy en día
reciben tantísima atención
las causas de la desaparición de los
anfibios podrían ser atribuidas a la
pérdida de hábitat en algunas zonas como
en europa o en áreas de américa del
norte que se puede apreciar en tonos
verdosos
tonos verdosos
a la sobreexplotación por ejemplo en
algunos países los anfibios son una
fuente importante de proteína y son
consumidos habitualmente y se puede
apreciar en tonos azulados sobre todo en
la zona de asia
pero para casi la mitad de las especies
que estaban en declive hasta hace poco
no se podían identificar los procesos
causantes de su desaparición
estos declives enigmáticos se producían
sobre todo en zonas neotropicales como
veis en tonos rosados y esto es en las
selvas de centro y suramérica y al este
de australia
en estas zonas se observan mortalidades
masivas de anfibios
puede que esta imagen os resulte
familiar ya que dio la vuelta al mundo
cuando se publicó en national geographic
e ilustra perfectamente la gravedad de
estas mortalidad es
pues bien en estos episodios se pudieron
recuperar anfibios muertos para su
estudio pero sorprendentemente no fue
hasta el año 2000 en que se detectó que
todos los anfibios muertos estaban
infectados por un hongo desconocido
hasta la fecha a este hongo patógeno se
le puso un nombre impronunciable y que
diré una sola vez listos
batrachochytrium dendrobatidis
y a la enfermedad que causaba la
quitridiomicosis ésta
este hongo que para vuestra salud y para
la mía a partir de ahora voy a llamar
vete ok vd es el hongo a partir de ahora
se introduce en las células de la piel
de los anfibios
como ya ha comentado la piel es un
órgano esencial para ellos y esta
infección lo que provoca es un
desequilibrio completo del organismo y
acaba provocando la muerte por un fallo
del corazón
bien la teoría actual es que vd es
originario de asia
la propagación y emergencia dvd al resto
del mundo es consecuencia directa del
ser humano
'hemos comerciado con anfibios para
mascotas para colecciones para el
consumo en algunos países incluso para
la investigación biomédica y es que los
anfibios han sido claves para algunos
descubrimientos en medicina
por ejemplo sabíais que los primeros
tests de embarazo fueron inventados
gracias a una rana
estoy segura que los más viejos de aquí
os suena lo de la prueba de la rana
no
bueno
si no lo buscáis luego
en muchos casos lo que ha pasado es que
especies exóticas han sido liberadas de
forma accidental o intencionada incluso
y se han convertido en especies
invasoras propagando este hongo por
nuevos hábitats
hoy la quitridiomicosis se encuentra en
todos los continentes y ha sido asociada
al declive de más de 500 especies de
anfibios y a la extinción total de por
lo menos 90
la extensión de esta crisis no tiene
precedentes en ninguna clase animal
así que podemos decir sin lugar a dudas
que la quitridiomicosis es la peor
pandemia de la historia
solo a modo de curiosidad
una de las especies extintas es la única
rana en el mundo que criaba su
descendencia en el estómago y
literalmente vomitaba a sus crías cuando
estaban listas para salir
adaptación es tan increíbles como esta
han desaparecido para siempre
pero es que los anfibios en nuestro país
también han sufrido las consecuencias de
la que traído micosis en particular el
sapo partero
este zapillo también tiene una
estrategia de reproducción única los
machos acarrean los huevos en la espalda
para protegerlos de los depredadores
y los machos chicos
cuando están listos para salir los
depositan cuidadosamente en el agua para
que nazcan ahí
pues bien el sapo partero ha sufrido
brotes de mortalidad en nuestro país
hasta tal punto que ha desaparecido por
completo en algunas zonas de españa
con suerte ahora sois un poco más
conscientes de la crisis de los anfibios
pero es posible que algunos de vosotros
os preguntéis y con razón si vale la
pena invertir recursos y esfuerzos en
proteger a los anfibios y a la
biodiversidad en general
para algunos de nosotros puede que la
biodiversidad tenga un valor en sí misma
intrínseco
pero es que hoy en día sabemos que la
naturaleza tiene un enorme valor
socioeconómico
los ecosistemas sanos proporcionan
servicios esenciales para el ser humano
desde la provisión de comida materiales
agua la regulación del clima la
regulación de la calidad del aire la
regulación del suelo bueno este suelo no
pero del suelo el reciclaje de
nutrientes y un larguísimo etcétera
el valor de estos servicios
ecosistémicos se puede estimar
económicamente y voy a poneros un
ejemplo
imaginaros que tenemos un humedal un
humedal filtra y limpia nuestra agua y
mantiene la calidad de ese agua
si destruimos el humedal vamos a tener
que construir una planta depuradora en
su lugar para mantener la misma calidad
del agua
este humedal por lo tanto nos estaba
ahorrando el coste de construcción de la
planta depuradora y podemos decir que
ese coste es el valor que tiene el
humedal en términos económicos
pues bien de este modo se ha estimado
que los servicios ecosistémicos puede
que tengan un valor que sea más de tres
veces superior al producto interior
bruto a nivel mundial esos son
muchísimos ceros
los anfibios participan en todo esto y
contribuyen ampliamente a estos
servicios afectan a la estructura del
suelo a través de la excavación de
madrigueras y ayudan a mantener la
claridad y la transparencia del agua es
que además controlan la producción
primaria a través de el consumo de
plantas y de animales que se encuentran
en el agua y ayudan a ese reciclaje de
nutrientes
también controlan las plagas de
mosquitos y de otros insectos
además de donde saldría nuestro príncipe
azul si no existieran las ranas
recientemente se ha descubierto que los
anillos también pueden contribuir
directamente a la salud humana en
américa central se ha visto que las
desapariciones de anfibios causadas por
la quitridiomicosis han resultado en un
incremento de los casos de malaria en
humanos a través de un incremento de los
mosquitos
si consideramos todo esto la pérdida
global de los anfibios probablemente
comprometer a la capacidad de los
ecosistemas para proveer servicios y
salud a la sociedad humana
queremos vivir en un mundo sin anfibios
o quizás la pregunta más correcta sería
podremos vivir en un mundo sin anfibios
sin ellos el equilibrio de los
ecosistemas acuáticos se puede romper
provocando reacciones en cadena
extinciones de otras especies que se
alimentan de ellos la pérdida de la
calidad del agua un aumento en las
plagas de mosquitos y otros insectos en
definitiva los ríos y lagos como los
conocemos hoy en día puede que cambien
para siempre
por eso es tan importante que sigamos
luchando y trabajando para la
investigación y la conservación de estas
especies tan olvidadas
vale maría entendemos ya nos has dado la
charla pero qué es lo que puedo hacer yo
en todo esto puedo aportar mi granito de
arena de alguna manera vas a darnos
alguna noticia positiva o yo es que todo
van a ser catástrofes
me gustaría terminar
diciendo que vosotros nosotros somos
clave
está claro que hemos sido la causa de
este problema pero es que también
podemos ser la solución y de hecho somos
la única solución
hoy formando parte de esta charla ya
habéis empezado a ayudar
nunca debemos perder esta curiosidad y
oportunidad de informarnos mantenernos
al día de este problema a través de
fuentes fiables y tomar parte en la
investigación de nuestros científicos
porque no
y si queréis ayudar más no participéis
en el comercio de especies exóticas los
animales salvajes no deberían ser
nuestras marcas mascotas
así que podemos disfrutar de los
anfibios sin necesidad de tocarlos de
hecho en nuestras manos pueden
transmitir al hongo patógeno y a otras
patógenos y pueden dañar la sensible
piel de los anfibios
los anfibios son especies protegidas y
nuestra calidad de vida depende de ellos
a partir de hoy
confío en que cada vez que veáis un
anfibio podáis ver la espectacular
historia que se esconde detrás de él
gracias
[Aplausos]